[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we're going to take another peek
behind the curtain of video game voice
acting showing you the actors behind
some of your favorite characters if
you've ever been playing a game and
thought where do I know that voice from
well this is the series for you in
today's episode we're going to take a
closer look at the cast of Resident Evil
3 the 20/20 version this is Capcom's
survival horror outing which isn't just
a remake of a beloved title it's a
chance to revise explore and change
characters and interactions like never
before so these boys actors are pretty
damn important so let's check them out
and see where you may know them from as
we return to the zombie infested streets
of Raccoon City most of our time will be
spent amongst the members of stars or as
nemesis would say
one of the last remaining stars team
members is the hero we all need the
legendary Jill Valentine voiced by
relative newcomer Nicole Thompkins then
I had one of those moments where you
realize something you think is really
unique and cool and super hipster and
like no one thinks about it suddenly
everyone actually if you played the
exquisite Middle Earth shadow of war you
already know her voice Nicole played a
drill a warrior and leader who fights
for her place in what she describes as a
man's world in that game she has a
British accent
we make them pay for every inch of
ground but they now hold it pretty good
for a girl from Texas
Gigi milady Nicole has quietly gone
about building her resume with regular
short film work and can also be found in
huge TV shows such as American Horror
Story where she portrayed older Scarlets
in the season finale you're just saying
that cuz I'm a member of the family that
ages but if I'm honest all I need from
my Jill Valentine actress is one line
here's the version back in 1999 you want
stars
I'll give you stars no pressure Nicole
oh and if you're wondering where you
recognise Jill's face from its taken
from a Russian model called Sasha absorb
/ why did I say like that anyway who
didn't own it Jill Valentine is also a
Russian catwalk model back in 1999 we
were introduced to Carlos Oliviero an
umbrella operative using machismo all
the foxy ladies loved my accent it
drives them crazy but now in 2020 Carlos
is being reimagined by voice actor Jeff
shine first things first we need to get
you geared up head up the street level
you'll find supplies there for me it's
the look of the character and then
figuring out who that character is and
then the voice sort of follows that
while Jeff's early career largely
consisted of short films and the odd TV
appearance he really came into his own
when he focused on the videogame
industry
he has lent his voice to the likes of
Red Dead Redemption - just calls for
mafia and Call of Duty World War 2 wait
your prodigal son
man that was a good game oh and if Jeff
wasn't already building up enough of a
reputation within the video game world
later in 2020 he'll be lining up
alongside voice acting royalty laura
bailey troy baker and nolan north as he
puts on the star-spangled spandex of
Steve Rogers aka Captain America in
Marvel's Avengers holy balls Batman
that's impressive wrong franchise story
anyway that's still impressive with two
of the biggest games of 2020 under his
belt I wouldn't be surprised to see Jeff
become a household name and future oh
and another one I just remembered before
I finished the voiceover Jeff Blade
Xavier in The Walking Dead I never
finished that game I really should go
back you sneaky little Carlos is another
character with a face taken from
somewhere else
the real dude is Benson Mokhtar which is
the best name you'll hear all day
how can he look like that when I seem to
have fallen down the ugly tree damn you
genetics joining Dillon Carlos on that
journey will be the remaining members of
umbrellas mysterious UBC s platoon
including Mikael Victor the gruff
Russian captain will be voiced by
william hope I am yes my team was sent
here to rescue submit as far as we were
concerned we thought the day was
finished wrapped and that we were gonna
do you know do some background stop for
some now a true old-school actor who has
been performing in the industry for
decades william started acting in major
Hollywood productions back in the 1980s
appearing in films like Hellraiser 2 and
the iconic
aliens wow that's true we've been
trained to deal with situations ledges
over the last decade he's moved away
from performing in front of camera and
now can be found voicing many of your
favorite characters strangely though yes
his voice has appeared in lots of games
but his main avenue for voice work has
come from this Thomas the Tank Engine
cue the dancing Goths under the bridge
mr. hope has been the voice of Edward
forever and he can also pull a little
Toby or rocky when the time comes
yes much too fast anyway good night
Philip after seeing this it's hard to
see that Russian military leader causing
any fear at all this guy used in Thomas
the Tank Engine also along for the ride
will be Nikolai zenovia Carlos and
Michelle's brother in arms so to speak I
can also hear the hardcore fans
fingertips itching telling me how I
mispronounced his name I'm very sorry
please don't hurt my family Nikolai will
be played by Neil Neumann who behind
that Russian accent he's actually a
fellow Englishman pop the Catalan
Tarquin
Thunder start killings did wheat-free
she's a reliable again pull the trigger
when it counts those days that are long
hard work yeah but they don't they feel
they're just playtime so they they feel
easier than your body may be
experiencing it's no surprise that Neil
started his career in rainy old England
appearing in TV shows like the bill
Harvey City and Holly yo who the hell am
I kidding most of you have not got a
clue what these shows are so I'll keep
this two video games
Neil not only lent his voice but also
his body but also his body in full
motion capture performance for the Final
Fantasy 15 tie-in movie Kings glaive
where he starred alongside Aaron Paul
and Sean Bean and by the way Sean Bean
he's from Yorkshire that's where I'm
from
not many of us escaped from here so well
bloody doesn't Sean what was I saying
oh yeah Neil Neil has been cracking out
mocap and voice acting work for a number
of major games including are you ready
for this get hyped horizon zero dawn
Sniper Elite and Planet of the Apes okay
the last one was not impressive but get
this he's also in the 2018 juggernaut
Detroit become human where he played
Elijah Kamsky the former CEO of cyber
life and one of the game's most
intriguing characters I'm sure you're
familiar with the Turing test here from
the simple question of algorithms and
computing capacity another mercenary
sent onto the scene by umbrella is
Tyrell Patrick who is played by Stirling
Solomon
damn right what do you think you're
gonna do whole city's about to be
microwaved there's just a lot of passion
and intrigue and love and all those
things so I think I think people will be
turned on sterling is a prolific TV
actor having appeared in shows like 24
The Vampire Diaries and Pretty Little
Liars whilst his video game resume isn't
as impressive
he has been cast as Lewis in the final
season of Telltale's The Walking Dead
I'll try not to spoil too much about
that role but let's just say things get
emotional so how do you feel about our a
minute deaths
rounding out the Umbrella biohazard
countermeasure service is Murphy seeker
kalos is close friend he'll be voiced by
voice acting legend todd haberkorn I do
need to get fired up for the big big 8
or 9 second yells or the battles Murphy
might not be the biggest character in
our III but this hasn't stopped Capcom
hiring one of the most prolific voice
actors in this industry for this role
Todd's made a name for himself providing
the English voiceover for characters in
some of the biggest animes of recent
years including Dragon Ball Z one piece
and fairy tale in fact he's already
stacked up over 400 seperate shows games
and movies to his name he's a living
legend he really is next up is the other
stars member left in the city join the
outbreak Brad Vickers good old chicken
heart himself is voiced by Darin O'Hare
Tim to find them but right now it's got
a hard-on for the only two stars left in
town you and me I'm pretty good like
playing against my friends I'm good I
can you know love playing through the
campaigns and then multiplayer online
Darren start appearing in fairly major
Hollywood productions early in his
acting career including films like
people like us and Transformers Dark
Side of the Moon
recently Darren lent his voice to games
like Marvel's spider-man Grand Theft
Auto 5 and lightning returns final
fantasy xiii but his biggest role
actually came in the Halo universe he
has performed both voice acting and
mocap duties for the character Thomas
Lasky appearing in Halo 4
the spin-off TV mini-series forward
until dawn and then a low five Omega
rounding out the cast we actually have
two characters that are returning from
the Resident Evil 2 remake first we have
one of my favorite characters from re -
Marvin Brown oh by Christopher Michael
Watson that officer you met earlier
Eliot he thought this secret passageway
might do the trick we realize oh we've
managed to do its lock ourselves inside
with it
Marvin is memorable for being one of the
few friendly faces in rezi - for those
of you who don't know resident evil 3
story takes place both before and after
re - which explains why Jill is able to
talk to someone who I killed in the
previous game I'll stop this lieutenant
I promise anyway as for the man behind
the character Christopher has appeared
in many TV shows and Netflix productions
such as scorpion SEAL team and Kevin
Hart's guide to black history we haven't
seen or heard his voice pop up in many
video games outside of Resident Evil but
he did appear in The Walking Dead saints
and sinners the VR title from earlier in
2020 have you noticed how many people
have been in The Walking Dead on this
list it's like they're all addicted to
zombies or something the other character
returning from Resident Evil 2 is Robert
kendo the owner of the gun shop and
he'll be portrayed by Ken Lally you're a
cop you're supposed to know something
how did this happen huh that scene
really made me realize the depth of the
character and how important he was the
story and just the whole story and I
love that name ken is a veteran of the
video game voice acting world and has
lent his voice to games for well over a
decade including the order 1886 Star
Wars Jedi fallen order far cry 5 and
most recently Mortal Kombat 11 where he
plays smoke here's something interesting
about Ken
Robert Kenda might be the first
character he lent his voice to in
Resident Evil but it won't be the first
time we've seen him in it get this Ken
provided the motion capture for Albert
Wesker in Resident Evil 5
I wonder if Robert Kendall can catch a
rocket like Albert Wesker finally let's
finish this video with one of the
biggest characters in the entire game
both literally and figuratively I am of
course talking about nemesis according
to IMDB the voice of nemesis in 2020 is
credited to someone named David cockman
everyone loves some caught no no don't
don't do it as far as I can tell they've
never appeared in anything ever before
literally nothing at all what a great
way to start a career then again I
suppose he won't have too many lines to
learn so that's about it for this
episode do me a favor if you're still
here please be a star and click like
also writing I Maggio sandwich and I'll
trying to find you and give you some
love thank you very much for your time
it's much appreciated I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]